Шановні колеги мабуть повага до лісу
починається з оцього Коли тиск у лісу
роздалася сьогодні ну пару знаєте
десятків гектарів Карпатських лісів як
ТСК і в цьому взагалі все ставлення до
цієї надто серйозної теми лісу говорять
коли корупцію не можеш подолати її треба
очолити це той випадок і ми вперше
бачимо насправді коли а сьогодні влада
яка мала би насправді а контролювати
вирубку незаконно лісів через повніх
свої структури в Міністерстві Внутрішніх
справ через прокуратуру створюєте ск в
парламенті витрачаючи невідомо які кошти
на друк невідомо яких оцих паперів на
кепочки курточки модні такі Африки де
знаєте замість того щоб дійсно займатися
лісом і коли парламент ржот на тому що
колі немає в залі півгодини шукаю його
це теж ставлення тому насправді тема
лісу дуже важлива централізація вирубки
оцих от лисів вона сьогодні очолюється
владою ми Закликаємо насправді до цієї
теми ставитись дуже серйозно і вважаєте
цей мій виступ запитом опозиційної
фракції європейська Солідарність до
влади до Міністерства внутрішніх справ
до глав обл
держадміністрацій до прокуратури з
питанням Так а хто сьогодні хоч один
відповів за цю вирубку лісів і для чого
Влада сама створює свої ж тиск в
парламенті для того щоб про своїх щось
або говорити або обелічивать - це ганьба
те що ви зараз робите